Durante a experiência eu senti muito relaxamento.
Depois, acho que voltei um bocadinho à realidade.
O Zé falou em doutor Pedro, que estava à minha espera.
Eu acho que voltei.
Como vocês dizem, é que é eu na real.
Mas durante o filme deixei mesmo ir.
Agora estou a cair mesmo na realidade outra vez, mas pronto.
Hoje não tive nada de especial, foi fazer o exame, a serigrafia, ou não sei quanto, é difícil dizer.
E depois passei o tempo todo à espera.
Estava dedicada para as 13.
Não tem nada assim a... Foi normal o exame de manhã.
Sempre com muito cuidado para picar.
Mas, quer dizer, houve aí dias que eu tive 4, 5, 6 exames de fazer.
E realmente aí há muito mais coisas a realçar de positivo.
Hoje não.
Hoje tive aquilo de manhã e depois fiquei à espera.